[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about whatever we want and
today we had to hear a an actor in a
musical artist just learned that about
him musical artist - I dabble what do
you play the kazoo
I mean estimate wise I play six
instruments but I've been doing more
like singing do you just [ __ ] dunked
on you so hard when you play the kazoo
he's like I play six instruments oh
that's like a lo Rogers F okay
that's different no I want to get that
vocoder I do
instruments you play I play clarinet
bass clarinet alto and tenor sax and
then bakes the snare do whoa where'd you
learn all that like is that concert and
marching band is that considered
cheating cuz saxophone through clarinet
are technically like the same kind of
instruments but different well because
their win is immense yes instrument to
start you off with clarinet there's no
way I can get around there that's only
has some instrument they had and they
don't want the bass clarinet he's like
you got a lot of wind so I was like
trumpet I wanted to play trumpet
Americans Miles Davis is one of my
favorite yeah yeah he told me how to
have the lips of it for it but it was it
was oddly like sexual how you did it a
lot of short shorts and he's like I just
don't you you know the lips for it yeah
wait wait you're with it this is great
yeah and what are you like oh yeah let
me prove I have this war I was like no I
think it's my first time playing
estimate you probably know better than
me I would have kissed a teacher
oh yeah [ __ ] and then [ __ ] I wasn't
I wasn't
Canada's on why can't the teacher
exactly yeah I don't know where that
came in at all like that to prove them
that my lips are worthy of trumpet
earring is not how you do it
um thank you like little balls like yeah
that's an ESD cells
dick some dick sucking lips oh okay no
no no elementary school job yeah it must
be some LA sir
oh maybe yeah st. Louis I don't say
Angelina Jolie you had DSL okay I can
see that because I just thought you just
I just want to kiss her
like I'm not alive remember back then
what DSL was do you remember with DSL $1
do you have to yourself and then oh my
god [ __ ] creeps man stupid ass that's
why I say [ __ ] is still my mantra it is
not a crock of Argos man my daughter is
like taller than me
and like how did it happen huh try that
happen teacher I just I don't know I got
it I got my mother's hips and height and
then from my dad I just got like this
pimping as your as your wife is she tall
she's she's about my five eight five
nine but yeah but my daughter's
biological dad was tall and his side of
the family was tall and my wife's dad is
talked to so she gets it from that's a
key piece yeah my wife was she was two
months pregnant but she told me like two
weeks out the we had I would have been
talking and I was like awesome ass to
stick around I gotta be today
you know what smashing a pregnant lady
like cuz I'm done they come before you
is it different it's a little bit
different because uh you know there's
like a baby in there yeah so you can't
go too crazy
well you're normal I guess like sexual
power an energy you don't it's it's it's
kind of like double dutch II at least it
was for me you're [ __ ] around the
baby no no you're just like I would only
do it dog you want to [ __ ] her but then
you're also like I don't know but
there's a baby in there
somehow a black guy and then there's
rust that hard yeah position you don't
want to shake the baby too much cuz I
already come out with a soft smile you
don't want a soft spot in the for you to
look like that's why do missionary that
way cuz I wouldn't want to yeah
absolutely about it you put you put like
a medicine ball between you and the
belly medicine ball there belly that way
you don't have a go into heart like an
air bag
the problem is I'm so dumb that I would
go I would be in Nicki's while she's
pregnant and then I'd be like oh my god
did I feel a hand around my dick I don't
know because I don't know I don't know I
don't even know that part of the bone
that they have calzones sincerely like
do you feel like no see because Anatomy
[ __ ] honestly gives me the
heebie-jeebies a little bit and so
whenever it's on TV or something oh my
god I'm changing I'm good okay gives you
DBGB yeah well it seemed the inside of a
human being good it's all that amniotic
section so you do know about the SEC
you'd like comes out that's why I put it
together I put it together chip what
were you saying I'm sorry did you guys
fill the babies move she will let me
touch I'm not doing the sex part during
sex that would hurt my dick with a thorn
at a you're just kind of like staying
away a little bit
don't this is too real it's gonna have
to come out is I just yeah last month at
was just finger banging I want Jonna
helps me go into labor yeah yeah Dadda
walking them tight [ __ ] and i walk
your hairs around the block because I'm
not going about what did the baby's hip
you're like stop yeah whatever I'm
saying like you don't want like outs I
would only go me a chap I wouldn't give
it a whole thing that's smart that's
safety awesome here the six inch then
footlong what [ __ ] that baby well that's
more than the whole thing for me a favor
anything you're the first black guy we
talked to today that has a big dick
really yeah large pool of people isn't
there well the other one didn't have one
that's why I've never been pressed about
the adsorb well so okay so then what's
your thoughts on the stereotype that
black guys have huge pair of gigantic
[ __ ] um well I can only speak to the
fact that I've only seen while mainly
seeing black horn and I will say that
it's oh you see that point the best oh
yeah yeah just cuz I'd like it's closing
your dick like real dog they're like you
know but is nothing like my big is like
it's a really good size but it's not
like porn D like it's not like like I
wouldn't want a dick like this like
that's so troublesome like if you you
imagine trying to sit down keep it run
with that like yo no shorts no
sweatpants flying is a hassle yeah but
the poor chicks love it
no they don't no they don't I could show
you the video I saw it this morning and
she was she saw it she was like [ __ ]
like she literally said porn blooper no
no no this was I like watch this before
[ __ ] hilarious dick and let it go to
smack your face is your like genuine
[Music]
yep and just give a plague-like over and
over Oh what kind of season wildest well
I saw this dude's master chick from the
back and like but he had his he had his
leg like all right hey why are you
smashing her whole like her whole head
is just like this is dismissed likes it
my friend gene likes that so that doubt
that was different what kind of [ __ ] are
you and you Ryan that you're watching
porn bloopers just the [ __ ] weird
parts of the internet man are you
watching it and you're like I hope
something happens soon then she farts me
like all right you know what your face
isn't so you find it that's my [ __ ] this
is to that load more videos tab that
should have take you down the rabbit
hole
I like the accidental cream pies nothing
accidental about a creep on it's always
acting sucks and then it broke the it
shattered it yeah see that's why don't
inside and they go oh oh no you can't do
that i watch acting porn is always
amateur porn for me I like it but it's
so crazy to how fast my mind is
disgusted like right up I'm like yeah
mmediately I'm so judgmental I'm like
this [ __ ] got all mismatched socks
raised her the room is dirty why are
your socks dirty you at home what
happening we need to talk about the
cleanliness of this house so I'm
immediately turned off and super
judgmental
I get remote doesn't have a back what
the [ __ ] I feel so gross about myself
they've got to be terrible people to
raveloe 780 people watch one called
beacon sausage pizza what no no [ __ ]
[ __ ] about weird ponies me don't get my
up I've seen it
that doesn't even sound appetizing
so that's where guys they would I used
to actually put it on in the background
when I had house parties because all
these shows like the pizza [ __ ] over the
pizza box here I know like hide your
pizzas she's like yeah and then he opens
it and his dicks cut through a pizza
yeah in the Senate is hanging through it
yeah and then what was interesting like
you're saying how you have that come
shame you're watching it and you're like
wait that one's clearly a delivery pizza
and then you're like sometimes like
that's worn on pizza that one's like a
tombstone why are they buying different
kinds of pizzas I think the thing that
will freak me out the most is that I
probably get turned on by the pizzas
opens up like me with a dick on my big
what if you didn't touch the dick huh
what I found in a box yeah like the dig
was under the Pierre the dick is through
the box put the pizzas around oh yeah
boy I would if they what if they cut a
wide enough hole around the pizza that
he'd never touched the day they don't
this is a no did this doesn't take out
here's a bingo like he's not gonna stay
fully erect signing up why they laid his
clothes so that that dick still touching
that pink there was a cutout adequate
folding room
watch it a dick touch the pieces ruin
for me if you're a dick touch the pizza
with you get some pubes on it you're
sweet it I can pick the peels off my
feet like you you wouldn't eat
everybody's ass would you trust your
wife enough yet hands right so that's
what it is like everybody like the own
sin yeah you setting the bathroom why
you [ __ ] but you ain't going their way
that's Jojo so that is crazy
/ okay huh i courtesy yeah the same is
still out so when you guys tour together
do you ever have like if you have to
ever have to share rooms yeah yeah yeah
me Tony it's cool for the most part I'm
super considerate like I always have in
sense I courtesy flush I run a shower
while poop so the steam not one up what
you eat the hot and wet makes you smell
it more no more like your what what's
the way is that the water is that your
poop wet from the ceiling that creates
yeah you know steam is wet yeah you have
dry poops no they're just solid then I
like I think this team is putting then
smell in the wallpaper though you say
well yeah it seems like putting a small
in the wallpaper up in with the towel
around just keep Y blue glaze over
that's how does he like weird geo
products I do i period wipe yeah well I
think is I still wipe like a kid like
I've been all the way over like this
know what Oh what do you go between your
legs
yeah that's not okay yeah the other way
around yeah I reach around you go
between your legs you're rubbing those
balls man
go like those and rather get to the
balls I go nah you can't pick up that
clean man it ain't in your balls or
dainty but I also use the bidet or I
always bring like a paper towel anyway
you have a good day
you have my house you are just I don't
know I super Busey super Busey our
office they're gonna be damned every
toilet other office
all right I'm sickened guy oh don't
touch it I don't put my balls clean as
buck all the time
Santa's use wipes eyes everywhere I go
like I've literally run out of rights
and then restore my bag to found like a
hand wipe for like a barbecue place
juice that's collected yeah but I ain't
worried about that I'd rather have a
clean-burning as in a dirty yeah yeah if
you know what the clean is coming from
FBI if you assume that when I wipe and
I'm wiping it onto my balls and you do
it the other way aren't you wiping it
onto your back no no you're just wrong I
tried away I know the [ __ ] parts like
of course I wouldn't either then you
have [ __ ] all over your back yeah that
is
that's gross oh I was just I wiped that
way since I was a kid and I kept it
through all the way until because yeah
that's how your wife taketh but it's
from the back to the front right that's
how you change that - yeah that makes
this for a child yeah when you're
holding the legs in the air - you say
what the baby you hold their legs now
like a chicken that way they don't like
come back and like he'll kick the poop
or anything like oh oh yeah all these
considerations I've never had to think
of kick the cheese my [ __ ] leg then
so that's all you consider it the shits
did you just have a [ __ ] dip bath where
you just like let them do their thing
you just [ __ ] like they only watch
the bottom we went to that barbecue
restaurant and you just [ __ ] put your
hands in the hole it's like a car wash
for your hands right why Howdy's or
something like yeah you man it it just
[ __ ] sprays your hands down and it's
nice and warm and you're ready to go
like yeah [ __ ] a duck that baby goes I
didn't that's it technology is crazy
you're still dirty no no half of the
body half of the body that's there but
like the Laurie nod I know that's what
gave its own mom Neverland
yeah she's there Dana should be 14 in a
couple weeks so she's already over five
eight five nine yeah she's on track now
run a tracking [ __ ] Oh
kind of mamita Mike no you're not that
oppressive go to you catch me I'll go I
have a friend who has a daughter who's
not his daughter and he was telling me
how there's this annoying age they reach
where they won't shut the [ __ ] up about
wanting to know their biological
whatever the [ __ ] have you gone through
that yet no no no I don't think that we
will cuz we've had conversations about
like I went out of the country last year
and this year and she couldn't go
because he's still the biological dad on
paper and so we can't get in contact
with him to get the passport oh so
hopefully if she does get to the point
she let you [ __ ] this guy I'm like yeah
[ __ ] that guy how long can he like hold
that she can
at 15 she can try to divorce as hell or
emancipate herself and then the parents
and then emancipate herself and then she
can get the paperwork signed no there
are ways though I mean you wouldn't know
more than me but I do remember seeing
like when I was playing for the passport
for my son they do have an option of
like only one parent is in the life yeah
child but you have to go through like
it's somewhat like we would have to get
a lawyer here in California and one in
Missouri or Illinois we don't know what
he stays so we know you have to like
before you even do that you have to go
through you have to show that you try to
reach out through snail mail through
email and social media you have all of
this documentation you have everything
that's a lot of work fine and then you
have to give the lawyer didn't have to
have a court date which could be set
from now to six months to a year and
then again you still have that lawyer
I'm both one because you're dealing with
family court and to the lawyer that
knows how to deal with like cross States
and yeah no did he disappear to avoid
child support Becca I don't know if he's
dead or what
in jail you never met him or never seen
oh no no I don't think so I don't think
I've ever met him per se so by the time
you got with your wife she was already
pregnant but he was already out of yeah
so we met in college and I was there
when the baby was born and then he came
back in the picture was like you don't
want to be my daughter's life so I kind
of back back for a couple months we lost
contact and then we got back in contact
we probably fell out to contact around
2009 when I moved out here Wow
and then we got back in contact 2010 I
mean 12 I'm sorry so I just got out of
jail didn't distress was selling like
dope some kids but it was like proving
that I was innocent it was just an ad
somebody on camera I was actually just
giving the kids candy they thought it
was dope no [ __ ] seriously no I'm
completely lie just commit to the bit
that's what it is if I could like make a
living a lie yeah oh my god yeah line is
the best I haven't believe that you wipe
this way now the problem is you believe
my wife I just got a little excited cuz
I was like oh we share connection on
selling drugs and stuff like like
narcotics you always just probably peels
I'm not gonna incriminate myself on cam
right anything for our dog to deny that
but if you need anything
[Music]